[تصفيق]
حلف النيتو لن نقدم المزيد من الاموال
لاوكرانيا حتى نعرف اين ذهبت 70 مليار
يورو تم تقديمها سابقا لاوكرانيا
اذا لم تقدموا لنا مئه الف قذيفه فسيموت
الف اوكراني كل اسبوع وقوتك تقر بثبات
وقوه الجيش الروسي واشنطن تتجه لتوريط
نفسها باسلحه محرمه في اوكرانيا والنيتو
يعلن ان حرق المصحف الشريف حريه تعبير
وليست جريمه وبوتين يرد وبقوه
يرفض الانصياع مجددا يتدخل لايقاف الحرب
الاوكرانيه وكييف وموسكو تقابلان طلبه
بالرفض وجزار بوتين يدخل دائره الشك
والخيانات وفرنسا تشتعل والوضع خرج عن
السيطره والمدرعات تخرج للشوارع
مثلث اوكرانيا الاسود
هاويه كقاعر جهنم لا تكتفي باي شيء وتقول
هل من مزيد الحرب في اوكرانيا تبتلع اموال
الغرب واسلحتهم نعم هنا رئيس وزراء المجر
يضع حدا للاستنزاف الغربي ويعلن ان المجر
لن تقدم المزيد من الاموال لاوكرانيا حتى
يعرفون ذهبت 70 مليار يورو تم تقديمها
سابقا لاوكرانيا وذلك بحسب روترز لكن
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تجاهل التساؤل المجري ليؤكد انه على تواصل
دائم مع رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه الجنرال مضيفا او ابلغ ميل اذا
لم تحصل على 100 الف قذيفه في الاسبوع
فسيموت الف اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره ليصل
الرفد الاوروبي باعلان رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي زود اوكرانيا ب 220
قذيفه مدفعيه واكثر من الفي صاروخ ضمن
حزمه القذائف التي تم تبنيها في مرسى
الماضي فهل تبتلع اوكرانيا هذا الكم
الهائل من القذائف خلال اسبوعين اما البيت
الابيض فاقترب من اتخاذ قرار خطير قد يجبر
واشنطن على مواجهه مباشره مع الدب الروسي
وذلك اذا ما وافق الامريكان على نقل
الذخائر العنقوديه الى كييف لتتمكن من
ادراجها في الحزمه الجديده من المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا بحسب شبكه سي ان ام
وهناك تحدث قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي في قمه
بروكسل التقليديه لصالح استمرار الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا ولكن هذه المره بشرط ان
لا يضر بامن ودفاع بعض الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي فان الدول اوروبا لن تقدم اي شيء
لكييف قبل ان تؤمن الدفاعاتها ومخازنها
التي افرغتها الحرب الاوكرانيه والح هنا
لازال مستمرا عن تمرد فاغنر الذي مات قبل
ان يولد ولكن هذه المره كشفت وثائق حصلت
عليها شبكه
عن ان نائب قائد العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
او جزار بوتين كان عضوا سريا بارزا في
مجموعه فاجنر واشارت الوثائق ايضا الى ان
ما لا يقل عن 30 من كبار المسؤولين في
الجيش والاستخبارات الروس تم ادراجهم
كمسؤولين مهمين في فاجنر فهل تورط جزار
بوتين وكبار قاده الجيش حقا في الانقلاب
الفاشل من بوتين هو من سمح لهم بذلك ليكمل
لعبته بالهجوم على اوكرانيا من حدود
بيلاروسيا فصارى بولندا ياتي من الم او
كارثه على وشك الحدوث وبوتين لا يلعب
ليؤكد كلامنا الرئيس الاوكراني نفسه
والذي طالب
بتعزيز الجبهه الشماليه الحدوديه مع
بيلاروسيا بعد فشل تمرد فاغنر وانتقال
مقاتلها الى بيلاروسيا على الطرف الاخر من
الانقلاب رفض قائد على الانقلاب
لقرار الدفاع الروسيه حول توقيع المتطوعين
المشاركين في منطقه العمليه العسكريه على
عقود مع الوزاره ليزيد الشكوك حول الامر
مجددا وهنا نعود الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
قتلت جنرالني واكثر من 50 ضابطا ومستشارا
عسكريا بضربه جويه عاليه الدقه استهدفت
اجتماعا عسكريا في كراماتورسكي في
اوكرانيا يوم السابع والعشرين من يونيو
براي هذه الارقام تحتاج مصدرا موثوقا
اليكم المصدر زرت الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت
مقتله جنرال واكثر من 50 ضابطا ومستشرا
عسكريا بضربه جويه عاليه الدقه استهدفت
اجتماعا في مدينه كراماتورسك شرق اوكرانيا
بينما اكدت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها تتقدم في جميع الجبهات وتقود زمام
المبادره لافته الى تحقيق بعض النجاحات
جنوبا في اطار الهجوم المضاد ضد القوات
الروسيه هناك اقر القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بثبات دفاعات القوات الروسيه على خط
المواجهه والتي لم تضعف اثناء وقوع التمرد
المسلح لباجنر في الرابع والعشرين من
يونيو ليصرح هنا رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا
السابق نيكولا ازارووف ان افولود مرزلنسكي
لا يناسب الغرب وخاصه الولايات المتحده
بسبب فشل الهجوم المضاد وبالتالي فهم
يبحثون بالفعل عن بديل له ومن الحرب ننتقل
الى الهدنه والوساطه حيث قال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
ان هدفه الرئيسي في اوكرانيا هو وقف قتل
الناس غير ان ترامب لن يستبعد تقديم كييف
تنازلات اقليميه لصالح موسكو ليرد مستشار
مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بانه
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عن جزء من اراضيها من
اجل وقف الحرب رفض الوساطه الامريكيه جاني
روسيا ايضا حيث انتقد وزير الخارجيه
روسيسركي
الى حل الازمه الاوكرانيه بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه واكدى هدف هذه التصريحات وكسب
المزيد من الوقت لتسليح اوكرانيا بشكل
اكبر ومن حرب اوكرانيا الى معركه اخرى
انطلقت بين روسيا والغرب لكن بانضمام
موسكو الى المسلمين هذه المره وبعد ان
احرق السويديون المصحف الكريم هنا صرح
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ان احراق القران
حريه تعبير ويجب ان لا يعيق انضمام السويد
الى النيتو الا تستحون يا هؤلاء لا تنسوا
ان هناك اكثر من مليارين مسلم واين هم
ابواق حقوق الانسان انا لا اسمع نباحهم
ليوجه الازهر تحيه اجلال وتقدير لبوتين
الذي عبر عن احترامه للقران موجها رساله
بانه لا يجب لمس الكتب المقدسه وعلى راسها
القران الكريم
فرنسا تشتعل بطرق رسميه واخرى ملتويه
تتدخل باريس لحل الازمات في العديد من
الدول لكنها لا تستطيع حل مشاكلها
وازماتها في الداخل وهذه المره دخلت فرنسا
في ازمه حقيقيه حيث اتسعت رقعه الاحتجاجات
في البلاد وذلك بعد مقتل فتى جزائريين في
السابعه عشر من عمره برصاص شرطي فرنسي
الجزائر من جهتها لم تصمت
من مقتل الفتى المدعو نائل وبشكل وحشي
وماساوي وعلى ذات الصعيد اعتقلت السلطات
الفرنسيه
667 شخصا خلال يومين ونشرت اربعين الف رجل
امن في مختلف ارجاء البلاد بينما ترى
الرئيس الفرنسي
اجتماعا
لخليه الازمه حول اعمال الشغب ليدخل
الفرنسيون في تطور لافت وخطير حيث افادت
قناه
الوزراء الفرنسيه اليزابيث اعلنت عن نشر
مدرعات بقوات شرطه في الشوارع الفرنسيه
على خلفيه اعمال الشغب برايكم هل تستطيع
السلطات الفرنسيه تجاوز هذه الازمه ام ان
الوضع سيتجه للا